[Music]
sending this one out to my evolutionary
psychology people yeah David buss
cosmides and to be yeah Jeffrey Miller
yeah we live in this till the day that
we die survival of the fittest wrong
survive there's a war going on outside
nomadic say from you can run but you
can't have to have all come to my block
you see some territoriality you place
where children killed it's the mentality
but get it straight makes it the
necessary strategy you got to play the
hand you're dealt can't magically escape
from the habitat that you was born in
three homicides in my neighborhood this
morning pop him and take the crow Kaduri
so warning started roughing up my young
cousin she's only 17 and californium the
oven plus the compression but she ain't
done nothing to keep your mouth shut
don't jump judgment on the lives we live
in just close your eyes and listen will
afraid down homicide statistics so if
you thinking the criminal mind is just
taken you mistaken this is calculated
risk taken with a banana situation with
the low life expectancy and a major
discrepancy between the haves and the
have-nots and you wonder why the padlock
on every cashbox smashed off come on you
can't call it pathological now that's a
logical you can try to understand it but
you can't stop it soaks not unless you
address the root causes the conscious
and unconscious decisions itself future
prospects come on it's obvious to be
keeps counseling homicide rate keeps
mounting which leads to steep
discounting and a lot of violence but
it's not a virus it's a rational
response to high-risk environments in
short time horizons with high stakes and
highly visible prizes
wonder why our criminal minded hey you
can't say we'll get satisfaction if
we're patient with self-control delayed
gratification when the only job that
pays of Casca Vegas adaptive the
ultimate plan cancellation to check the
facts and recent data releasing shows a
pattern of increasing competition a
bunch of young guys all struggling
status weaken causing the crimes to make
the social fabric weaken and life
expectancy also predicts teen pregnancy
the need to leave a legacy sanity never
be completely controlled contraceptive
Leanna's transparent magic pure cane
would never meet the grandparents let
they follow the Bristol Palin plan for
Parenthood the men they say these young
girls are so damn careless get pregnant
before marriage if such a tragedy
apparently it's also a reproductive
strategy especially when you can see
them adjusting actively when their
circumstances change in both the cases
of the young ladies ladies in the male
risk takers we see people to gas into
the situation and it's the same in
different places and with different
races this is not about ethical
justification it's evolutionary psych in
is just insane
still people call this behavior
maladaptive because of our reaction when
violence happens but if you really want
to change the outcome maybe we should
just start questioning how it's adaptive
and the bottom line is that iniquity and
life expectancy are the ultimate causes
of crime and the results are crying to
me that's true that you can find
together and a feedback loop but I got
some things to make now so I'll be back
soon just don't ask me what I'm about to
do slag because I can't say so it's left
untold facts until my death my ghost
will stay alive survival of the fittest
wrong survive that's right we've been
dissed killed the day that we die
survivals are the same only the strong
survive
which it possessed till the day that we
died survival's are the same only the
strong survive that's right with every
desk till the day that we got survival
of the fittest wrong I'm surprised yeah
we live again till the day that we die
survive a little to say only the strong
survive that's right and with evidence
till the day that we die
survival affect only the strong only the
strong strong move strong yeah sending
this out to all my evolutionary
psychologist Delia Wilson is Steven
Pinker's robber right yeah gave us from
Wilson yeah that's right gather the
evidence make it real make a real human
intelligence represent yes human nature
human nature to the core i'ma get mine
and you get yours don't question my
actions unless you're ready to make a
little addition before I'll make a
subtraction gives you up in traction
that's right
love scrappy
[Music]
I'm here talking today with dr. Martin
Daly dr. Daly is a professor of
psychology at McMaster University in
Hamilton Ontario and author of many
influential papers on evolutionary
psychology his current research topics
include an evolutionary perspective on
risk-taking and interpersonal violence
especially male male conflict and fast
in his wife late Marta Wilson were the
former editors in chief of the journal
evolution and human behavior and former
presidents of the human behavior and
evolution Society he was named a fellow
of the Royal Society of Canada in 1998
Daly is one of the main researchers of
the Cinderella effect and has been
interviewed many times in the press
about it so I'm very pleased to be
talking with dr. Daly this morning it
seems to me that he's one of Canada's
most outstanding psychologists and
perhaps you could say that about
psychologists in the world and he's done
some incredibly interesting research on
the relationship between inequality and
male violence and inequality another
topic student so welcome dr. Daly Thank
You Jordan it's nice to be talking to
you well I'm looking forward to her
conversation a lot so you just wrote a
book which I'm going to show people
called killing the competition and I
just read it it was very interesting so
I thought maybe I could get you to start
by talking a little bit about the book
and and also how you tell us tell us the
story that would be good a good thing to
do well the general issue that is
addressed in the book is the
relationship between economic inequality
which is usually in debt
says income inequality and homicide
rates and it's been known for a long
time by sociologists that income
inequality is the single best predictor
they've got of homicide rates across
countries across states within the US
across cities within the US and some
other kinds of jurisdictional
comparisons and there's been controversy
about why that is and whether in
equality itself is truly the problem or
whether it's just a correlative
something else and then this book I try
to make the case that no inequality
really is the problem and some of the
arguments that have been advanced for
suggesting that it's a mere correlate of
violence rather than in some way causal
environments are wrong so can you tell
us a little bit about how you calculate
inequality and what the measure is yeah
income inequality there's a number of
different measures that are used by
economists so I'm just borrowing the
dominant ones from economists the
number-one one is something called the
Gini index GI ni I used to assume that
that was some kind of acronym but
actually it was the name of an Italian
economist and it's a measure that is
ranges from zero to one it would be zero
if everybody had exactly the same income
or exactly the same wealth if you're
doing wealth inequality and it would
approach one as income or wealth was
concentrated more or more in the heads
of few and then a single individual and
in principle would go to one in the
extreme if all wealth were held by Bill
Gates and done the rest of us had
anything
now you analyze the Gini coefficient
have different levels of jurisdiction a
so I noticed in your work that you've
looked at countries and states within
countries and I think that's
particularly true in the u.s. so tell us
a little bit about what you found yeah
well with within the US and again this
has been known by sociologists for some
time within the US n cross nationally
the Gini coefficient is a very good
predictor of homicide the correlation
tends to be on the order of point
seven in many studies which means that
the variance in either measure 50% of it
could be accounted for by the
variability and the other measure but in
say between homicide and income
inequality and actually it even works as
a neighborhood level my late wife Margot
and I published some analyses in Chicago
that showed that income inequality was a
very strong predictor of homicide rates
across neighborhoods within Chicago tell
us a little bit about what you did in
Chicago because not that research is
extremely interesting and also when you
did it
let's see we did our work in Chicago in
the early 90s and at that time Chicago
had very high homicide rate not the
worst in the United States but one of
the worst in the United States and in
fact have more homicides every year than
the whole of Canada which makes it a
substantial enough phenomenon that you
can sort of look for causal factors or
correlates without a lot of stochastic
noise in Chicago Chicago divided up into
some 77 I believe neighborhoods by
there's a long-standing tradition of
urban sociology in Chicago and there's
these sort of well recognized 77
neighborhoods in any way for these
neighborhoods we were able to amass a
variety of neighborhood specific
information including on income
distributions on homicide and so forth
of working with the Chicago Police who
were collaborators in some of this work
and Margo went to the Illinois
Department of Health to try and get
information on other death rates and
birth rates and demographic structure of
each of the neighborhoods and she wanted
to compute the life expectancy because
the idea that she had was the local life
expectancy would he affect the extent to
which people were willing to sort of
escalate dangerously in competitive
situations in competitive City and that
was our construe of what most homicides
in Chicago were about where guys killing
each other when dissed in bars
circumstances in which there's some sort
of competition and it gets dangerous and
our basic
idea there and elsewhere has been a lot
of the variability in homicide rates the
most violent volatile component of
homicide rates has to do at this
male-male competition where where and
when does it get dangerous um where when
does it sort of dampen down and for
Chicago anyways the Illinois Department
of Health had never nobody had ever
computed neighborhood specific life
expectancy but the data were available
to do an age specific mortality and so
on was available to do it and so we
computed a specific life expectancies
income inequality and many other
variables that criminologists have
considered relevant and past studies
racial heterogeneity and blah blah blah
and try to see what were your best
predictors of homicide and in that
particular study everywhere else we
worked we mostly found income inequality
to be number one in that particular
study income inequality was a very good
predictor but the best predictor was
male life expectancy at age birth or at
age 15 and in order to compute love
course you say homicide rates homicide
reduces male life expectancy so you have
to remove homicide statistically as a
cause of death and say life expectancy
met up the impact of homicide that was
our best predictor of homicide rate so
life expectancy is very variable in the
city of Chicago and I assume in other US
cities I mean the worst neighborhoods
male life expectancy at birth was down
in the fifties as bad as in the worst
countries in the world in the best
neighborhoods male life expectancy was
up in the I think was over 80 or in the
high 70s in any case corresponding to
what you might expected Scandinavia or
the places with the best life expectancy
in the world so it's a huge range that
was our best predictor then if you try
and do a multivariate analysis where you
look for well what else predicts um the
residual variability and there wasn't
much residual variability the
second-best indeed the only secondary
predictor that seemed to be
statistically significant was income
inequality across the neighborhoods that
was that was the thrust of our study in
Chicago and I'd love to see more work
life expectancy as a predictor of
violence the diversity 10mm al
criminologist mark wheeler tried to do
the same thing in the montreal but he
found that in montreal the difference in
life expectancy for men between the
worst and the best neighborhoods was
only six years whereas a Chicago it was
twenty four years I think so why do you
think accounted for the vast difference
in life expectancy between Chicago and
Montreal and was life expectancy itself
associated with income inequality oh yes
I mean that's part of the problem of
course in all this kind of research here
it's not experimental research you don't
control independent variables and
everything of potential interest is
correlated with everything else so you
know income inequality alone accounts
for more than half the variance and
homicide rates across Chicago
neighborhoods so does life expectancy
alone so does percent below the poverty
line alone you know special ratings are
all correlated with each other and so
try to tease apart what's most important
is tricky well so whatever the less the
low life expectancy in Chicago
neighborhoods is not due to violence and
student it's due overwhelmingly to
differential disease introvert ization
of medicine in the US was so extremely
tight we were doing this research
emergency room skin the worst
neighborhoods in Chicago had closed down
because they got bankrupt they didn't
have enough money to remain open and
therefore if you got stabbed or shot in
a bad neighborhood in Chicago you had to
be transported somewhere else to try and
keep you alive because there was you
know the hospitals and shut their
emergency rooms or had shut down
completely so there's all sorts of
factors that contribute to to
differential death rates but you know
kids in the worst neighborhood are
exposed to high levels of when there's
some evidence that lead exposure in
childhood is big predictor of
variability and life expectancy all
kinds of internal diseases they were
more susceptible to the effects of bad
nutrition they were more susceptible to
so if you
if you divide causes of death into
so-called external causes which
basically means homicides suicides and
accidents and internal causes which is
more or less than what we ordinarily
think of as disease
internal causes were still the biggest
source of differential mortality across
neighborhoods so you can make by the
sounds of it you could make a reasonable
case that the social safety net in
Canada is flattening out at the bottom
of the of the income distribution
especially the provision of health care
and no I also read it was informed a
while back that the rate of
entrepreneurship in Canada is actually
higher than in the US and part of the
reason for that is that because
healthcare is provided people can take a
risk of walking away from their jobs
without putting their family completely
at risk and so one of the perverse
effects of socialized medicine is that
it elevates the rates of
entrepreneurship so I also wanted to
mention know your your work was
absolutely striking to me because of the
effect sizes now for people who don't
know about how to compare us exercises I
should point out that you never see a
correlation of 0.7 between any two
variables in the social sciences the guy
named Hank Hill who did an empirical
analysis of effect size comparisons
about four or five years ago might be
longer than that now and he concluded
that 95 percent of social science
studies had effect size of 0.5 or less
and so to see a correlation of 0.7 is
absolutely overwhelming when you also
take into account that measurement error
is decreasing the potency of the
relationship to some degree so and when
you take into account that that those
about that point five represented
studies that were published because they
got something yes exactly exactly so so
point seven is absolutely overwhelming
I've never seen effect size is that big
between two variables of interest in any
other domain that I can recall and the
other thing that that's worth pointing
out and we can talk about this a little
bit too is the other thing that's so
radical about your research is that it
and and this is what emerges out of the
out of the manner in which the Gini
coefficient is
is calculated because it's only a
measure of relative poverty and it's the
predictor you also generated data
indicating that places where everyone
was relatively poor or say relatively
working-class like North Dakota and some
of the Canadian provinces will add very
little homicide rates and also places
where everyone was rich right so to
reiterate what you're seeing is that
what's driving male homicide is the
existence and for correct me if I'm
wrong the existence of a steep economic
dominance hierarchy that makes it
difficult for the young men to obtain
status through what you might describe
as conventional and socially productive
means and so instead they turn to
violence as a means of establishing
status and most of that's within race
and between young men jockeying for
position is that all correct yeah I
think that's a pretty fair
characterization it's worth stressing
yes that income inequality is in
principle and in practice to societal
from just average income or percent
below the poverty line or other measures
of so-called absolute deprivation
they're often correlated all right you
know income inequality across a certain
set of jurisdictions may be fairly
strongly correlated with the percent
below the poverty line for example and
be surprising if it was not usually
correlated but but they're not
necessarily as you said yeah so you did
with straightener you were one of the
first people to demonstrate were you the
first in fact maybe that it wasn't
poverty that was causing this kind of
crime it was a relative poverty and that
that changes the interpretation of the
situation absolutely dramatically so
tell us a little bit about why you think
the male's are competing in in this
deadly manner what's driving that
behavior well it's very interesting I
think I think men are sensitive to are
interested in relative positions status
of maintaining face in competitive
billions and it assets all millions are
a bit competitive and the willingness to
use violence partly
can be thought of as kind of a disdain
for the future or I want money now I'm
willing to do something that threatens
my life like escalating competition or
not backed out or not walk away from an
insult because I'm thinking very
short-term of the rewards for for being
passive you know if you're if you're a
nice of prosperous university student of
age 20 you have good life prospects your
chances for eventually becoming
well-paid of maybe people will laugh at
this are still reasonably good your
chances for eventually burying are still
reasonably good if you're the same age
kinda guy in a turban ghetto with a 48
percent unemployment rate or something
like that then you have very much more
head with uncertainty about the
stability of whatever income you do get
with with of the future unknown then
you're more willing to take a risk now
in the pursuit of status now in the
produced suit of sexual opportunity now
in the pursuit of monetary rewards legal
or alissa now and also make this the
face like social reputation is the one
resource you've got if you've got other
resources you could walk away from
threats or disrespect of and reap your
rewards later if social status is all
you've got that it becomes an important
thing to defend so I read some research
awhile back it looked at the
relationship between socioeconomic
status among men and number of sexual
partners and also socioeconomic status
among women and number of sexual
partners and that's another domain where
you see these kinds of whopping
correlations so the correlation between
socioeconomic status for men and number
of available sexual partners is about
0.6 0.7 whereas for women it's negative
0.12 and so do you think so do you think
that it's reasonable
to assume that either at the
phylogenetic level or the auto genetic
level leave either evolutionarily
speaking or even as a consequence of
rational calculation that's part of the
reason that men are perhaps the main
reason that men are engaging in these
status competitions is because of female
hypergamy is that a reasonable is that a
reasonable hypothesis hypergamy and as
you say sip of simple access I mean
there there is there the association
that you mentioned it's presumably a
very long-standing one that is to say
that benefit status of resources have
had access to partners for sure and
probably multiple partners
simultaneously or serially to a degree
that met of lower status have-nots
there's high variance in eventual rep
reduction among males in mammals
generally and although the situation is
less extreme and people that have many
other mammals the same is true for
people I mean when you say they have
high variance compared to what well high
variance compared to women for example
the variability and eventual
reproductive success is lower for women
to permanent or husband
now you say sexual access to a but I
think that's exactly the right level to
be what you have in contemporary
societies but the reason why that
matters is because ancestrally that
translated it to differential
reproduction for in a moderate
environment of which you know
contraceptive technology is available
especially to women that that that
correlation may be broken down but the
motives to seek sexual opportunity of
remain relevant so one of the things
that I wanted to talk to you about too
is the IQ you you made a comment in your
book about Adrienne rates and Adrienne
range is written a book recently about
the biological predictors of criminality
and you make a strong case that it in
some sense the turning to violence
that's characteristic of men in
uncertain situations is rational because
it drives it actually legitimately
drives status increase and that produces
a variety of positive effects so it
some sense it's a rational response to a
radically uncertain environment where
competition is high now reigns would say
the biological type researchers they
look at they look more at the individual
level and conclude that it's individuals
who have various forms of prefrontal
damage or character logical issues
associated with antisocial personality
disorder that are more likely to engage
in violent acts and you can track that I
mean rashard Trombley has done some of
this work in Quebec you can track the
emergence of aggression at an individual
level all the way back to children at
two years of age because it turns out
that children who are - are the most
violent children particularly the boys
but mostly a subset of boys who kick
fight hit and bite and steal at - most
of whom are socialized by the age of
four but a subset of whom are not
socialized and then they become they're
more likely to become the lifetime
offenders and and so what I'm wondering
is maybe you can reconcile the
difference between the two research
streams like this imagine that as the
economic gradient increases and the
dominance hierarchy becomes steeper and
steeper the men who are prone to be
violent like it's the disagreeable men
that start to be violent first the other
ones that have an impulse control
problem or that are characterological 'i
like like the violent two-year-olds that
our character logically predisposed to
be violent it seems to me that those
would be the ones that you know as the
pressure increases those men who are
more prone to violence for other reasons
are going to be the people who react
with violence first do you think that's
a reasonable hypothesis yeah I think
that's a very reasonable hypothesis I
mean my objection to Adria raids book
was um that I think he fast you know he
there's definitely evidence that many
kinds of of violent criminal offenders
have got something wrong with their
braids Adrian rave wants to extrapolate
to the conclusion that violent criminals
and indeed criminals in general have got
something broken about their brains and
it's like criminality is pathological
well criminality is not pathological
people steal
for cosmetic related reasons the crime
is a if you like god help us social
construction in the sense that of
certain behaviors are criminalized by a
larger social group in order to deter
them because self-interested individuals
would otherwise pursue them you know how
do you make people stop exploiting
others stealing from others by
criminalizing those activities imposing
penalties and you know there's a
rational choice of stream of theorizing
with in criminology that the other
people like Adrienne Rhea just dismiss
out of head no no criminal offenses are
pathological yeah and I think that's
silly
well it seems not necessary yeah because
it isn't that difficult to make a
marriage between the two issues like one
of the best predictors you know I do
research on individual differences in
personality and the best personality
predictor of incarceration is low
agreeableness that's one of the
dimensions on which men and women differ
the most and so as you become more
disagreeable you become more self
oriented I would say and that can push
past the point where you're so
self-interested that you're willing to
prey on others and so those are the guys
that as well as the guys who lack
impulse control those are the guys the
first guys to turn to violence let's say
when the socio-economic conditions
become sufficiently unstable so that a
conscientious approach is not tenable
yeah that's good at the marriage between
that kind of thinking and particular
relevance of inequality is that there's
guys at the top who are like the Bayeux
of people you describes or people doing
very well who are very happy to exploit
others but the costs of individual bio
in action are high enough of the
opportunities to exploit other people
through financial needs through your
lawyers through whatever tactics are
available to you know well-heeled
bullies are are safe enough that they
opted to behave in those directions
right because they go
their long-term future is relatively
stable and so that long-term planning
and regulation of behavior actually play
out an important economic role and you
know in that in the case of somebody
like Donald Trump I mean he looks like
somebody who's suffering a little bit of
it impulse control problem especially
sort of during the night when he wakes
up and does his Twitter account is to
close at head but he's he's rich enough
to bully people in other ways that
actually had non-violence although come
to think of it the famous remark that he
made during the campaign about women of
suggests perhaps that depends on your
definition of heads on violence I guess
that qualifies okay so there's a very
large quality of research that indicates
that alcohol is a major contributor to
criminality - especially with regards to
men and so about 50% of people who are
murdered have a decent blood alcohol
level and about 50% of murderers and I
think that's partly that staff is equal
equalizers I think because much violence
among them is exactly the sort that you
described where it's a status dispute
and it's more or less a toss-up who's
going to come out as a winner but then I
guess what's happening with alcohol
perhaps is that because it's a
disinhibitor because it reduces anxiety
and anxiety is one of the suppressors of
aggressive behavior that men who are
already on the edge let's say because of
the unstable environment and the Steep
dominance are are also more likely to
lose control when they're drinking and
maybe that's also fuel this is something
to that I'm curious about me you can
think about it as a rational calculation
but but I'm also curious about the
degree to which is fueled by emergent
negative emotions so it's tempting for
people who are in steep dominance
hierarchies to regard the system as
unfair and to become resentful and angry
about it as perhaps they should be I'm
not suggesting that that's necessarily
an irrational response but it seems that
if the anger is simmering underneath the
surface that it's waiting in some sense
for an opportunity to break free and
alcohol in a bar or at home perhaps
provides that that
root yeah what you say makes eminent
sense to be available it's probably
worth injecting a bit of a caution about
the word rationality generally what one
talks about rationality and crime but
perhaps especially in confrontational
violence the point is not that the
person is making good and carefully
weighed decisions I mean I think you
know emotions are the handmaiden of what
I would call ecological rationality they
help you know how you should feel about
certain things and how you should react
to them and the rationality claim is
more a claim of this person gets riled
up resents ex and their Eddie should
there's good reason to get riled up and
resent X but the fact that alcohol
perhaps dis inhibits so that you know
the truly rational balance between
inhibitory and aggressive emotions is
altered the idea that ration that
alcohol of interferes with with
cognitive process to the point that
people are start making stupid decisions
when they're drunk like to get behind
the wheel or whatever I think this plays
very heavily into the reason why so many
homicides tend to happen it contexts
like two drunks insulting each other in
stick or you know people who are
somewhat under the influence of alcohol
insulting each other rather than not you
know with you if you have more if you
have more mental wherewithal at the
moment you probably have better
capacities to confuse they to defuse
dangerous situations through of you know
ways the Dalton Hale losing face by
being articulate um great exactly that's
right you have other tools at your
disposal rather than immediate recourse
to your fists thank you yes mm-hmm
so if I remember correctly to in your
Chicago studies this is one of the
things that I found particularly
fascinating was you track the
consequences of killing someone in
Chicago and the consequences were
something of the following sort well
first of all you are
likely to be charged with something like
second-degree murder it would be
difficult for the police to find people
to testify against you and if they did
generally what they would say is that it
was a two-way altercation and so in many
cases you could plead self-defense often
it didn't go before a jury because the
perpetrator plea bargained it down to
manslaughter the sentence was something
on the on the order of a couple of years
and people were generally out of prison
in 18 months with a substantial boost in
their social capital because now they
were like dangerous sons of not
to be messed with and that was quite
clear and also perhaps also improved so
to speak by their sojourn in prison that
is if I got that right except for what
detail well actually there Chicago
Studies we didn't have as good follow-up
information as what you're talking about
this this was a earlier piece of
research in the city of Detroit that
that led to most of those findings but
but yeah exactly
of Hartley it's interesting we had a we
had a single year sample of cases in
Detroit and there were I think 590
homicides to Detroit in that one year
1972 at which time Detroit did have the
highest homicide rate the u.s. a large
majority of these are male male disputes
of some sort of status disputes usually
but sometimes robberies and just as you
said um witnesses aren't likely to come
forward and the prosecutors are
stretched they don't write they don't
have the resources that they would need
to pursue every case and so they many
cases were dismissed I did not even
prosecuted everybody plea bargain
something like approximately half of all
male male macho dispute homicides in
Detroit that were solved we're not
prosecuted of the expectation that there
was a plausible self-defense argument
the place you know with with the jury
that of the house that were prosecuted
almost all of them
yeah we're plea bargained down to
manslaughter and the majority of the got
a conviction threose three years 50
percent time off for good behavior if
you behave nicely you go to
Jackson state prison in Michigan of 18
months later you're back out on the
streets of Detroit and Margo in
particular was very addressing the
question of whether killing in these
contexts might even actually ultimately
pay off for guys I tend to the view that
actually killing is overstepping the
bounds of utility that that's
consciously during that deadly threats
are very self-interested and effectual
let's definitely get but that actually
following through on them is maybe be
you know that that none functional tip
of the iceberg but I honestly don't know
that that's true in these kind of cases
for that for exactly this reason that
guys get some social capital out of
having done it well hypothetically among
the yanomamö tried tribes in in South
America and South America I believe for
center I think it South America yeah
yeah the the more warlike men have a
much higher reproduction rate the ones
who killed more now I don't know
obviously it isn't necessarily the case
that that's directly translatable but
there is some utility in being a
successful warrior that's actually one
of the reasons that I think that
capitalism so to speak is
underappreciated because in a very I'm
speaking in a very specific sense is
that there are disagreeable and warlike
men and some of them are very powerful
in many ways not only physically but
intellectually in character illogically
and and with with great ambition and the
thing about capitalism is that it
enables them to wage war in a manner
that's that's not deadly and to become
successful that way and to channel their
their their intense competitive energy
into something that well I think often
is often for social good now it depends
on how disagreeable the person is and
how selfish they are of course but
people like that also tend to get
punished in their in their cooperative
interactions with other people yeah i
mean i partly agree but I also feel that
they often toward the social good is a
bit hopeful I beat up to the degree that
people are successful at a fairly
unrestrained capitalist
of competition it's usually at the
expense of large numbers of people at
the bottom but it depends how restraint
that capitalist competition is I was
thinking of social good as in better
than war yeah
no better yours for sure right I got the
bar for sure at sometimes at sometimes
the way you succeed is by producing
goods that actually make people's lives
better
oh no quarrel with that so now I also
wanted to ask you I read in the last
couple of chapters of your book you
turned to what I would regard has more
political issues and so I I will and I
am I'm very interested in inequality
because will regret recapitulate for a
minute so your work and the work of
other people seems to indicate that as
inequality increases and dominance
hierarchies get steeper not only the
young men get more violent and so
society becomes less stable but there's
also detrimental impacts on things like
population health and and and that are
and that was that was documented quite
nicely in the spirit level so I'm going
to address a couple of criticisms of the
research and and then I want to ask you
I want to have a discussion about your
your more prescriptive views if that's
okay so so the first issue someone just
emailed me this while back and when I
was talking about inequality and they
said well what about places like China
where the rates of inequality are
starting to skyrocket quite
substantially and have been for you know
several years maybe maybe several
decades yet the the homicide rate
doesn't seem to be budging much and so
that I thought well that was interesting
maybe there's something different about
East Asian communities they tend to have
very low crime rates to begin with like
places like Japan for example a very
local crime rates and so I'm wondering
if what you think about that is that a
reasonable criticism and how would you
address it fair enough
well I don't I don't think we can
characterize you know Orientals
as less violent than Occidental's or
anything like that I think you know
history tells us otherwise that there's
been a lot of severe a dangerous
violence in Japan in history and in
China in history I don't know how good
data we have on Chinese homicide rates
but what I've seen is that they have
been going up a bit lately but still the
point that inequality has been
skyrocketing to be partly there's an
interesting question about time lags
losses that summary on people you know
how sued is an increased inequality
effect going to play out as nasty
interpersonal behavior and you know
people respond to inequality as a result
of their lifetime experiences you know
you are talking about young kids already
very young children already being
predictable in the extent to which
they're willing to you know use violent
tactics against other people end up you
know a saying three and four-year-olds
to give you some surprisingly good
prediction of how they'll behave as
adults it's not inconceivable that the
effects of inequality even are
influencing people's development
prenatally and so you know the you -
right environments than they experience
as a function of inequitable
environments the stresses and front
social comparisons and so on that happen
if those environment could be
influencing them at all life stages so I
don't think we have any strong basis for
expecting rapid changes in equality to
be accompanied in the short term by
rapid change in violence of that said
there you know it's certainly the case
that there's other things that matter
and government controls are one I think
I think strong governments that
monopolize the legitimate use of
violence can keep a lid on violence for
a long time I you know I I would
question whether they can keep a lid on
it indefinitely but they could keep a
lid on it for a long time if you if you
execute all charged murderers um I
presume that that would keep the
incidence of murder down and not only
because those people could be
recidivists great so there's an element
potentially of authoritarian control
young men do I think though that I think
is
is particularly interesting is the time
lag argument mean we don't know over
what period of time precisely inequality
has its pernicious effect and maybe it's
not even the span of one lifetime in
adieu I do you have any data on that
that would help help answer the question
I did I did make reference in my book
killing the competition to one
sociological study that was looking at
effects of inequality unmoor tality
generally at the notion that inequality
affects mortality generally is mediated
by what you were talking about about
health effects the idea that you know
stresses and front social comparisons
produce a greater vulnerability to
stress-related disease and said in fact
many diseases most diseases maybe even
are stress-related and their ultimate
impact on people so there's this one
sociological study by a guy named Sheng
in Ohio State which sought effects of
economic inequality of mortality in
general
it keeps the conclusion that there the
effects were lagged that the maximum
impact on current mortality was
inequality seven years ago which sounds
kind of funny but he had analyses which
seemed to show and I'm a bit wary about
the legitimacy of these analyses but
they seemed to me to show they seemed to
show to him that it equality of a few
years ago affects the test that you'll
die now um net of the effects of you
know agent sex and other predictors of
mortality and that there's sort of a
cumulative consequences of many years of
emergence of past inequalities so seven
years ago was the worst but six and
eight also mattered additively five
years ago and nine years ago also
mattered additively ten years ago also
mattered so that how bad the inequality
was in your past seems to affect your
likelihood of dying now the effects of
violence have a have a looked at that's
hard to figure out how you could get a
decent enough data set to do that right
but I don't think it's impossible okay
so so with
regards to health effects so I'm going
to lay out an account of them and you
can tell me what you think about this
all right so your your your your your
brain is always trying to calculate to
some degree how good things are going
for you and that's an extraordinarily
difficult calculation because life is
uncertain and ultimately I'm certain and
it's difficult to predict the future
except perhaps by using the past as a
marker and so you what seems to happen
is that our nervous and our nervous
systems are always interested in how
prepared we should be for emergency at
any given moment and as far as I can
tell there there are a number of ways
that we calibrate that one is baseline
levels of trade neuroticism
so that's sensitivity to anxiety and
uncertainty and emotional pain and so
you seem to be born roughly speaking at
a at a at your average level of
neuroticism which can vary substantially
between people it can be also adjusted
at puberty and then the environment can
move you in one direction or another so
for example if you have a highly anxious
child and you encourage them to go out
and explore then you can move them
towards the normal range if Gerry Kagan
has demonstrated that quite nicely okay
so the first the first estimate of how
worried you should be about the future
is like genetic roll of the dice some
people will be born extraordinarily
worried roughly speaking and some people
will be born hardly worried at all and
then that can be modified by that by the
particulars of the social environment
right so then the next thing that seems
to me to be part of the calculation is
comparison how well are you doing
compared to others
yeah and that seems to be adjusted by
mechanisms that associate perceived
social status with serotonin
serotonergic activity such as you move
up a dominance hierarchy your serotonin
levels rise so that your impulsivity
which would be partly sensitive
sensitivity to immediate reward declines
and so does your sensitivity to negative
emotion whereas if you plummet down to
the bottom of a hierarchy you start to
become more reward seeking and also more
anxious and the reason for that more
anxious and is because the bottom of the
dominant turkey actually is a more
dangerous place to be because you don't
have access to don't have reliable
access as reliable to shelter or food or
mating resources or healthcare and you
even see this in birds you know so if a
flu sweeps through an avian population
it's the dragon birds at the bottom of
the dominant hierarchy that die first
and so then one more thing and then then
tell me when so this is that the other
thing that seems to happen is that as
you plummet down the dominance hierarchy
and your mind settles into a more
depressed and anxious state the levels
of cortisol that you produce chronically
rise and cortisol is a good hormone for
activating you but in but in but in high
doses high continual doses it starts to
produce brain damage particularly in the
hippocampus and it also suppresses
immunological function which makes you
more susceptible to infectious diseases
so that seems to be approximately the
process and so it's no wonder that
people are trying to flee away from the
bottom of the dominant turkey I've seen
reasonable yes give me a give me a
moment I've got a coffin blow Latos okay
hay fever season in southern Ontario
okay yeah I wish I were a better
behavioral aide Oh chronologist and do a
bit more with more expert into some of
the processes that you're talking about
but a lot of that big sets to be the
front social comparisons I mean the
evidence certainly is that it's more
stressful to be low ranking but high
ranking we've had a little bit that old
hot big a very high rank puts all this
burden of decision-making on you and
that's terribly stressful it makes you
vulnerable to heart attack and blah blah
blah the day to say the opposite the day
to say that's not true the more power
and Status and if you like
decision-making authority you have the
less vulnerable you seem to be
distressed related diseases
so you know a lot of what you're saying
makes makes eminent sense to me then the
developmental story that you're telling
I mean I I think it's right that people
I don't know how important the throw of
the genetic dice is I think it's also
extremely interesting puzzle
evolutionarily why there's as much
heritable genetic variability in
seemingly important domains as there is
and I'm not convinced anybody has you
know really understands what modulates
how much variability there is but any
case that things are adjustable it
responds to what you encounter and it
responds to social status perceived
social status and response to social
comparisons makes eminent sense to me
and again I I don't know enough about um
the putative damaging effects of
excessively prolonged exposure to say
high cortisol levels to be sure whether
there is a still some adaptation some
actual functionality to the response to
long-term exposure lurking beneath the
seeming breakdown in the system because
it just seems to be the sort of a
Darwinian on evolutionary of social
scientists said psychiatrists and
psychologists have been too quick to
assume pathology when they see the
states of affairs that fill indeed have
damaging consequences but they had sub
nevertheless have sub utility I wish I
do a little more about well I think both
the low serotonin and the high cortisol
levels are interesting in that regard
because what does happen is the
combination of those two things makes
you a more impulsive and be more
prepared for emergency action both of
those things are very useful in an
uncertain environment that's detrimental
the detrimental consequences seem to
occur as a consequence of prolonged
overload is that because your body is
utilizing imagine what your body is
doing is utilizing more units of
resource per moment of time
because of the necessity for preparation
for unexpected events and that can
become physiologically exhausting in the
long run so I think it does it it seems
to me that those biochemical effects do
underlie the sort of adaptive responses
that you described except that you know
too much is too much and yeah if it's
hard to live at the bottom what that
means is you age faster and you don't
live as long and you also have higher
susceptibility to disease and maybe in
some sense that's the price you pay for
the adaptive the impulsivity it's also
necessary to give you a chance to shoot
back up the hierarchy if that's the sort
of thing that you're looking for yeah no
I can't help thinking about sort of the
evolutionary theories of of senescence
and bodily repair that the four pioneer
by Sir Peter Medawar back in the 50s and
develop more by George Williams the idea
that many many things involve some sort
of trade off between expenditure for
expenditure of energy of accumulative
resources of capacity in the pursuit of
something now at the expense of reduced
capacity to be successful later and and
so you know one reason why these chronic
States they have long term the damaging
effects is because selection against
being in these chronic states has not
been strong because those who are in
them for a long time didn't historically
tend to live very long anyway and there
they're being if you like motivated or
prepared to engage in high-risk
activities that at least have some
chance of short-term payoff which is
more or less like you said actually
while I'm you know you talk about this
miss let's call it a misbegotten idea
that there's stress at the top of the
dominance hierarchy just like there is
stress at the bottom and the stress at
the top is responsibility and
decision-making and all about and you
know what I do believe that there's
truth in that but there's an important
another important biological element
that needs to be considered
so there's a there's plenty of work done
in the domains of clinical psychology
and some of this is psychophysiological
and neural physiological for that matter
showing that a stress of an equivalent
magnitude as fewer negative effects if
it's taken on voluntarily uh-huh because
what happens what happens is that if you
voluntarily engage in the stressful
activity your approach systems are
activated rather than your defense
systems and the approach systems are
associated with positive emotion and
with and with much whereas the negative
emotions are associated with this
defensive posturing that includes
preparation for emergency and that's
much more physiologically damaging and
so whether something whether you pick up
a load voluntarily or have it thrust
upon you seems to make a big difference
to how heavy it is and that's that's
very that's a very interesting piece of
set of research studies as far as I'm
concerned it's quite fascinating the PAP
can be the case yeah ok so let me ask
you another question let's get down to
we might say brass tacks here so we can
make a case that inequality destabilizes
societies and and and cranks up the male
or male homicide rate and the
destabilization occurs because young men
become more and more unpredictable and
violent and so you could make a
conservative case as well as a liberal
case for not having a society that takes
inequality to an extreme because
conservatives at least in principle
should be concerned with the maintenance
of social stability over the long run so
but but okay and so then you might make
a case for income redistribution but
that gets very very troublesome because
it's not that easy to redistribute
income and and that's what I want to
talk to you about so you know we're in a
situation of course where the top 1% of
the population controls a substantial
proportion of the economic resources and
the top 1% of that top 1% controls the
bulk of that now I looked into that
quite deeply and that that distribution
it's not a normal distribution of money
it's a prio distribution of money but
the weird thing about burrito
distributions and so that's a
distribution where many many people end
up with zero and you know just a few
people end up with a lot is that a
Pareto distribution characterizes
zero-sum games that are played out to
their conclusion so like monopoly
everybody starts in the middle but then
random trading produces an eventual
pre-owned shaped distribution where lots
of people start to stack up on the loser
side one person accelerates towards
victory until finally everyone's at zero
except one person so it's the logical
outcome of random trading game so that's
the first thing that's interesting about
the Pareto distribution the second thing
that's interesting is that Perino
distributions they credo distributions
emerge in every domain of creative human
production not just the distribution of
money so for example we did an analysis
of the creative achievement across the
lifespan using using an instrument
called the creative achievement
questionnaire so what it was assess
people's levels of confidence across
thirteen potential domains of creative
activity and so we were looking at
production rather than creative thinking
per se right right although those two
things are related and quite tightly we
wanted to know who actually accomplished
things in the world and so for a musical
ability for example the zero score would
be I have no training or or talent in
this area and the maximum score would be
you know my my original compositions
have been played for international
audiences and so we've now administered
out to hunt to hundreds of people and
the median score is zero across all
thirteen domains it's a very very
precise Pareto distribution with a few
people who are the outliers producing
the overwhelming majority of the goods
and you also and that there's a there's
also a law that this ola price came up
with back in the 1960s governing the
output of scientific papers and he found
that the square root of the number of
people operating within an academic
domain produced half the
papers that were published in that
domain right so so that's not so bad if
there's ten researchers because then
three of them are producing half the
papers but if there's a thousand
researchers operating in a domain then
30 of them are producing half the papers
okay so and then one more complication
and then I'm going to let you let you
have at this so I've been looking for
now you can think that the Pareto
distribution which by the way
characterizes the distribution of wealth
in every known society although the
degree to which the distribution is
skewed differs you can say that the pre
dough distribution is a consequence of
the of the final playing out of a random
trading game but then here's the
complication this is something that's
been you know bothering me for years
there are predictors of long term life
success in in relatively stable
societies and the best predictors are in
this order the first predictor is IQ the
second predictor is trait
conscientiousness and it's about half as
powerful as IQ and the third predictor
is low neuroticism and it's about half
as powerful as conscientiousness so if
you get a good measure of IQ and a good
measure of conscientiousness then you
can predict 25% of the variance in
performance especially across managerial
administrative and academic domains and
then with regards to entrepreneurial
performance you can use IQ land and
trade openness which is the creativity
measure so there are powerful individual
differences that are driving
differential performance and also
driving this Pareto distribution and so
it's not merely a random game although
how these people manage to make it into
not a random game is beyond me but there
is evidence that that our society does
hierarchically arrange itself at least
to some degree by ability and competence
and so then the question is how do you
factor that into the equation when
you're thinking about practical let's
call them income I don't think it's so
much income redistribution is that it's
an attempt by society to stop too many
people from stacking up at zero
and therefore logically turning to
violence and that sort of thing as an
alternative well as well as an attempt
to just um improve the level of justice
in society the idea you know I mean
especially if there's an element a
strong element of randomness and who
ends up where then there's something
unjust about large numbers being stuck
down at the zero but you know you say
how is it possible to redistribute but
countries vary in the extent to which
they do this they vary in the extent to
which they tax inheritance they value
vary in the extent to which they tax
large incomes they vary in the extent to
which they provide education and health
care try and provide relatively
universally try to make opportunity
relatively universal they vary in these
things and you know some of the happiest
countries in the world and they think
the most productive countries in the
world of the Nordic countries Japan have
been relatively equitable because they
rigged this game more than some other
countries if you like so you know you
say that what stacks up on the top tend
to be the most competent creative people
and employment to some degree we have a
meritocracy and to some degree we do
have a meritocracy but you know the four
wal-mart heirs have as much wealth as
the hundred billion poorest Americans
put together and they did nothing to
hurt it um you could say well they're
high quality people because they got
half their genes from Sam Walton that he
did something to hurt it that seems like
a pretty weak argument for why they
should control that much well if if
inheritance were more severely taxed in
order to provide public goods for
everybody with the society be worse off
would flattening out that curve of
accomplishment actually reduced
productivity you know I think there's
some there think there's some evidence I
wish I could pull it to the forefront of
my mind about the utility of
distributing grant money of more or less
equitably in
certain Sciences the amount of science
you get for your buck is better when you
give lots of lots of people relatively
small graphs W gives a small number
people relatively large grades
yeah well that'sthat's interesting
because I've worked in the grant system
in the US and in Canada and grant system
in the u.s. is more of the give a few
people a huge amount of money for
variety and in candidates distributed
more equitably and I must say that I
would prefer the Canadian system now I
agree with you and I think the Canadian
system has been moving regrettably in
the direction of the America partly fed
to the field of science of course if you
need a bloody Hadron Collider that you
need millions millions of dollars if
you're a psychologist like you or me
things seem to work better in many ways
when you fund a higher proportion of
grants with a with a lower variance and
the demos awarded when I first came to
McMaster there was exactly
no I should say when I first came but I
say let's say the late 80s and early 90s
essentially everybody in the department
how to research grant for either insert
that natural science is a de jure
Research Council of Canada or shirt with
social sciences and Humanities Research
Council of Canada
usually the former in our particular
Department everybody in the department
had an active research lab everybody
created the opportunity for two or three
students to do a bachelor's thesis of
their lab each year then with things get
more variable people start people people
who are being productive we're getting
out a scientific paper to doing decent
work making a contribution to knowledge
when they start being denied these
grants you know when you refuse two or
three types of the competition and say
well the hell with it you know I need
them I've got to here I've got a good
pension lined up had to go become a real
estate speculator the opportunities for
the dissemination of research
opportunity to a larger number of
students shrink I think it's it's been a
disaster in certain areas and you know
an area where I was raised Admiral
behavior studies
if you just look at either the number of
papers and top-ranked journals of by
country according to how they allocate
their funds or how much money is
allocated to it the money allocated to
it is the less strong particularly you'd
expect and the equitability is a
stronger predictor suite in Canada of
used - last time I looked both rag far
above the United States in numbers of
papers per capita getting into top
quality research journals in animal
behavior you know against what a little
anecdote the way but but I would be very
surprised if there's a subjective to
this note well I wonder no to play
devil's advocate the thing about
distributing research funds more
equitably is that you are distributing
them among a population that's already
being extraordinarily highly selected
for capability so it seems
counterproductive because it's for all
the flaws of the university system which
are manifold it is still extraordinarily
difficult to become a professor it's a
it's a multi tiered selection system and
so the people who do become professors
are on average very intelligent and on
average very hard-working and we know
that because we know what the predictors
are of success in academia and its
intelligence and conscientiousness
unsurprisingly although creativity seems
to play almost zero role really well I
think yeah but that's partly because you
know science is an algorithmic game
right and just beating away at it busily
is a very very powerful mechanism so I'm
not the least bit cynical about that I
mean the reason that science works is
because it's in some sense it has the
aspect of factory production it can be
distributed anyone can learn to do it
and you get a long ways by nibbling at
the edges you know it I can tell will
continual slow progress when millions of
people are doing it is progress that's
plenty rapid so ok so so there are
definitely situations in which denying
people resources seems to be completely
counterproductive and that would be one
of them so now the other question though
is I would say and and also that's the
thing there's also an effective means of
funneling resources to let's say a wide
range
professors it actually works the problem
is one of the problems with general
income redistribution is as far as I can
tell is that we don't really know how to
do it very well and one of the I mean
look here here's an example you can tell
me what you think about this so I used
to work I just live in northern Alberta
when the oil price pratical oil boobs
were going on and my observation was
that if you wanted to make money in
Alberta when an oil boom was going on he
didn't go out and work on the rig's
although if you did that you could make
a tremendous amount of money now it was
all young man who did that pretty much
say between the ages of 16 and 25
something like that and they were making
fantastic amounts of money but they
verged almost all of them came out of it
with nothing to show for it because they
would work for two weeks and then go
into town and just have a blowout party
for four days and spent everything they
got and our expensive cars and wreck
them and so forth so it was reckless
behavior that I think was akin in some
sense to that to that to the to the
steep dominance hierarchy violence and
and that sort of thing that for status
tea seeking that you're describing the
people who really made money were the
bartenders right because they absorb
gold all the excess profits and actually
generally generally speaking we're
comparatively speaking we're able to
utilize the money properly now the point
I'm making is that an oil boom is a very
effective way of distributing wealth
down the economic ladder but it didn't
necessarily seem to me to be a very
effective one because it didn't because
the money flowed back up to the top 1%
damn near as fast as you could shovel it
downwards and that's that's the thing
about that damn purrito distribution is
that it seems there are people there's a
there's a as a group there's a
scientific subfield called econo
physicists and they actually they
actually model the distribution of money
in an economy using the same equations
that model the distribution of a gas
into a vacuum so so there's something
that's natural law like about this that
the economists call it the Matthieu
principle right to those who have
everything more will be given and
from those who have nothing everything
will be taken and I don't think that
we've done a good job of grappling with
the actual complexity of this and we can
to split up into politically opposed
what would you call camps and argue
about the solution to inequality and the
left-wing solution is something like you
know distribute the money take it from
the rich especially the undeserving rich
if you can identify them and give it to
the poor and the Conservatives say well
no the Porsches the poor should boots
drop themselves up and maybe be provided
with more opportunity and that might
equalize things but it isn't clear to me
that we're actually grappling with the
magnitude of the problem no it isn't
clear to be either but what you say
about equalizing opportunity for example
is a necessity distributing resources
because one way you equalize opportunity
is by have a universal high quality
health care that's paid for by some sort
of government revenues some taxes picked
up somewhere
free education universal access to
education is certainly another that's
you know it's another way that in effect
you create a more egalitarian society so
I mean there are there are certain
domains certainly education and health
care maybe some others that are not
spraying to mind well I suppose the
improvement of various sorts of
infrastructure that you know make it
easier to get from point A to point B um
you know yeah so that's publicly
subsidized treads things like that could
certainly be contributors as well now
that's equalizing in its own right you
don't think you what are you giving it
specifically to anybody else then
there's things like a guaranteed minimum
income and at first it sounds like a
crazy idea the idea that you know you
should just um we should take government
accrued resources which come from some
sort of taxation and we should just make
sure everybody has 15 thousand bucks a
year to start or something like that um
it sounds kind of wacky because the
standard argument against it from the
right is but that it will undermine
incentives and nobody will produce
bugger-all if you know if we could all
be welfare right well want to be welfare
queens Bhosle and
where this stuff has been tried by
understanding is that that it's been
surprisingly successful that there was
an experiment but at Ola we're a middle
of income was tried for a while we're
and gosh yeah I remember that I know
back before Finland by a Hutu Troian it
was about to try it Manitoba has tried
it it was an NDP government I think
which then were replaced by conservative
or or nominally liberal government then
sort of canned the results but the
results came to light later and shows
that for example the number of people
who chose not to work did not go up
under this and that it have various
beneficial effects I think it rebates VC
but I think even the idea of putting
money in the hands of everybody from the
great collective wealth that has
accumulated could be socially beneficial
could be economically beneficial could
be environmentally beneficial on a
5-footer
I wanted that certainly the debates like
education and health care that's in
effect a kind of redistribution rate but
uh that seems easy to effectuate I mean
easy if not easy to effectuate in terms
of convincing people politically or
overcoming the propaganda against it but
a whole bunch of obviously a whole bunch
of our wealth is embodied in the
infrastructure yeah I really noticed
this for example when I lived in
Montreal because Montreal is a great
city and one of the things that
distinguishes Montreal from most cities
that I've lived in especially western
cities is that people live in the city
they don't live in their houses yes and
the fact that the city is
extraordinarily livable so you can walk
everywhere there's always something to
do that's exciting there's a
tremendously active street life means
that there's access to infrastructure
and social capital related well just
distributed everywhere and now yeah
that's a lovely thing so secure I'm kind
of looking for solutions to the purrito
distribution problem that conservatives
and liberals alike
could agree upon and so some of those
you outlined improve the infrastructure
of our society because that those are
public goods that benefit everyone that
also improved productivity it seems to
be no downside to them it also raises
employment improve the quality of
education right from right from day one
which is something that I think we do a
very bad job of and then the issue with
health care it's my understanding that
the Canadian health care system for it
and it has flaws because it's of course
dealing with an impossible problem still
uses much less of its capital on
maintaining itself and for example
having to maintain an infrastructure
that collects money I know that the
hospitals in the u.s. spend something
some substantial proportion of the
revenue I can't remember precisely but
it's between 17 and 30 percent if I
remember correctly just gathering the
money for their services which seems to
be rather counterproductive use of the
resources and I wonder how much is spent
on billboards advertising their
hospitals to drive the interstate
highways of the US it's astonishing how
much of information about you know come
to such-and-such where we have the best
cancer yeah doctors and it isn't well I
mean Americans pay a lot further health
care they do indeed they do a DNA spent
three years there yeah recently and we
paid a lot for health care coverage that
turned out not in fact to be held up
thorough a coverage right well when I
lived in the state's doing I a decent
coverage of but I was teaching in Boston
there I had a pretty good program but it
wasn't I wouldn't say it was manifestly
different from my Canadian experience
which is being mixed but of course it is
very important to note that health that
that making people healthy is impossible
because everybody its second ages and
dies and so it's an impossible task and
it also indicates to me that that's
perhaps one of the reasons why it
doesn't fit so nicely into a free-market
model because the free market assumes
that there's not infinite demand for
something and there is actually near
infinite
for health care especially another dying
there's that there's also just you know
it's it's an impossible problem because
an aging population it's an impossible
problem because you know governments
have one of the determinants of the
costs of the health care system is how
many empties you've got out there
billing it and governments have a
tendency to unresponsive I restricting
the number of new medics um so as to
restrict the number of people billing
but this is not much of a solution but
you have large numbers people try to
find it family doctor unsuccessfully
okay so there is there is some
meritocratic structure to our society
insofar as IQ conscientiousness and
openness predict long term life success
and that's a good thing because that's
an indicator of of health in the society
I would say it's it's if your society is
set up to to to allow people who are
intelligent and conscientious nearer the
pinnacles of power structures that's a
good thing for everyone now you can
still have an argument about how steep
that gradient should be but then with
regards to the the guaranteed annual
income issue I'm also concerned that the
importance of individual differences
there are not being considered so for
example I don't know what people who are
extremely low in conscientiousness would
do with an annual income because they're
not inclined to work and it isn't
obvious to me that providing them with
an easy way out is the answer because
providing unconscious people with an
easy way out seems to be actually quite
counterproductive and conscientiousness
is a you know it's a decent predictor of
long-term success we don't know to what
degree necessity is a motivator which is
of course the conservative argument so
so and we also don't know how
homogeneous is and small a society has
to be before income redistribution
programs will actually be successful it
seems easier to implement them in
relatively homogeneous societies like
the Scandinavian countries or the Jew or
Japan which is where they tend to have
been implemented with more success so
that's a call
complicated phenomena as well and then
the other thing that's really going to
come up on as hard in the next ten years
I would say this is how it looks to me
is that I think computational devices
are a multiplier of intelligence and
conscientiousness because if you're
smart and you know how to use a computer
and and you're diligent so as a
conscientious person would be then
you're much more deadly than you would
be without your computer because it
multiplies you and there's a huge
difference between someone who really
knows how to use a computer including
knowing how to program it and someone
who's you know literate enough to use
their iPad to to do a Google search and
so I think one of the things that's also
driving inequality particularly in
societies like the United States is that
increasingly people who are smart and
conscientious can do a tremendous amount
of work without having to hire anyone so
we have these tiny companies that employ
almost no one that gathered massive
resources to themselves and that's going
to be a problem well here's a good
example here's one thing that's coming
so you know the Tesla guys are working
pretty hard on autonomous vehicles and
making a lot of progress and they're not
the only ones obviously but you know the
biggest employer for males in North
America is as driver I didn't know -
yeah yeah it's the biggest single
employment category so you know we're
increasingly eradicating the possibility
for people who are on the lower end of
the intelligence distribution and the
lower end of the conscientiousness
distribution to find a place in society
and it is possible that providing them
with with minimal resources to survive
might be sufficient to solve that
problem but I doubt it because as they
say you know man does not live on bread
alone and it seems to me that people
need the quest the degree to which
people need to find a productive
incredible place in a functional design
is something that we haven't yet we
don't know the parameters of that know
going I don't disagree I be the the of
course the loss of decently paid work of
and two dates the major computer
revolution to some extent or at least
the you know modern electronic device
and your phone could do everything
revolution and you know I live in
Hamilton Ontario where we're formerly a
lunch bucket held with with an enormous
number of people working in decently
paid of working class jobs and those
jobs that evaporating and if drivers
evaporate maybe work is going to change
work opportunities are going to change
and I take your point that people need
something that they can think of as
useful work useful work you know it's
interesting we're talking we're two
males talking about this and we're
probably thinking from a somewhat male
perspective there's a lot of useful work
that is minimally or not at all
compensated than a predominantly female
don't needs day care kinds of things of
various so-called charitable activities
and so on and you know the idea that
people need something to occupy their
time with that feels worth wild and
enters them into a social arena where
they engage with other people that they
come home satisfied that they've done
something useful they also you don't
have a ticket at every pot besides I
mean a work opportunities shrink and if
the next Mark Zuckerberg can employ a
hundred people to pull in tens of
billions of dollars then where's that
going to come from it may come from
various sorts of unpaid work with a
guaranteed income that you know enables
that work to be unpaid and still be
fulfilling me I don't know I don't know
well that's a good thing to think about
I mean maybe maybe people will learn how
to go out into the community and
spontaneously do useful things although
I can tell you that my experience trying
to find gainful let's call it volunteer
employments for people who are on the
lower end of the ability distribution is
being absolutely it's difficult beyond
imagine
because it turns out that finding a
volunteer position is actually no less
difficult than finding a job for example
you have to go through a relatively
complicated process of police screening
for most jobs and you have to produce a
resume and you have to be able to work
in an office environment and you know
you need to have all the abilities that
you would have if you were actually
having a real job and so that that makes
things complicated as well so yeah I
want to come back also to what you are
saying about the predictive power of IQ
and conscientiousness which I don't
dispute and I'm also not one of these
people who suffers under the delusion
that these things are totally open quote
socially determined close quotes they
need to understand and believe that they
have high heritability and identifiable
genetic resources in that variability
and so on but you know the standard old
joke used to be you can tell me because
you don't worry about personality
psychology that I do instead oh don't
joke history that everything's 50%
heritable that's done that but pretty
much anything that you could measure as
a trait that has any stability within
the lifetime also turns out to have a
heritability somewhere near point 5 but
there's the other point 5 of you know
some people have low IQs because they
were exposed to too much leg didn't to
see you know I believe that
conscientiousness this can probably be
what I believe you suggested earlier
that we know something about this
already about developmental determinants
of of shifts in conscientiousness and so
you know we have to caution ourselves
against talking about these individual
difference factors as if they are
beautiful attributes of individuals that
are going to undermine any sort of
progressive improvement of yeah well
their dad's is for people are going to
create bad byproducts of attempts to
produce social justice it's just gonna
you know you're going to leave your your
dumb country it just people out there
being parasites or something well you
know there is of course decent evidence
that the socio-cultural
effects on IQ I mean the Flynn effect
which is named after the man who
described the the phenomena indicates
that the average IQ has been increasing
quite substantially over the last
hundred years and the reason for that no
one knows for sure but one of the
putative reasons for that is that we've
lifted the bottom out of catastrophe so
there aren't people whose IQs are
stunted by my exposure to zero
information during critical
developmental periods and who didn't get
enough to eat yeah I've gotta say severe
malnutrition their adviser information
yeah yeah yeah exactly so we've we wiped
out in many ways we've wiped out the
worst effects of privation
and that's increasingly true as well on
the worldwide scale world stage you know
there's about a hundred and fifty
thousand people a day right now being
lifted out of absolute poverty by UN
standards the fastest improvement in the
history of the world by a huge margin
and also about three hundred thousand
people a day being hooked up to the
electrical grid so we are making some
progress
removing the absolute privation problem
which is a net reveal problem the
problem with most of the attempts to
raise IQ is that they don't change the
variance in IQ they tend to raise the
average IQ across the population and
that leaves the inequality by Q
inequality problem basically untouched
so there have been studies trying to
estimate how much socio-economic
pressure let's say you have to place on
an individual to raise their IQ lowering
it's easy right because making something
worse is always easier than making
something better well if I remember
correctly if you take a an identical
twin who's adopted out at Birth in order
to produce a 15-point increase in IQ
compared to the other twin which is a
one standard deviation increase and
about the same as the average difference
between a university student it is in
average state college and an average
high school student you have to move the
one twin from the 5th percentile of
socioeconomic status
the 95th percentile so you need about a
three standard deviation improvement in
socio-economic conditions to produce a
one standard deviation improvement in IQ
so it looks like it can be done but it's
but it's expensive you know and and I
say I see what you're saying I'm kind of
surprised um actually I've been given
you know we just mentioned malnutrition
as one possible source of low IQ what
possible developmental source I'm kind
of surprised that to the degree that the
flit effect might be due to things like
a reduction of the number of people
exposed to severe malnutrition that it
wouldn't have also simultaneously
truncated the variance a little bit that
seems like they said well it has or let
me restate that it has truncated it has
truncated the variance although the data
on that isn't clear isn't as clear so
but but I do believe that it's a
reasonable inference to make that the
variances being truncated it's also
hidden to some degree because the IQ
tests are always renormalize
look retrospectively and see what's
happened to the variance so but uh the
other problem too is that you know you
get these stories now and then about
these companies that come out with
claims that their brain exercises can
improve IQ and the literature on that is
damn dismal I can tell you it's that the
Holy Grail is to produce cognitive
exercises that produce a legitimate
impact on fluid intelligence and like
there's been a lot of work done on that
and the answer so far is that it doesn't
work so what about forget what about the
video gaming I mean I know there has
been the suggestion that playing video
games actually improves at least some
aspects of intelligent yeah well there's
a couple of studies that indicated that
video games might improve spatial
intelligence but but here's the problem
and and I think this is this is a
critical problem and perhaps an
insoluble one or at least no one solved
it is that what you get is that if you
if you exercise yourself substantially
on a given game you can radically
accelerate your performance in the game
so you can get much better at those
specific skills sure but you don't get
generalization across cognitive sets
which is what you're really hoping for
because I thought I thought that was the
claim from somebody
well they have shown some increases in
spatial IQ but there's not very many
studies and I would say they're far over
balanced by the other side of the
message equation which continually says
and I've looked at this because I'm
really interested in the improvement of
IQ I mean that's that's the holy grail
in some sense and that and and be that
the overwhelming preponderance of
evidence suggests that you don't get
generalization outside the narrow domain
now why that is and even this it's even
worse a because you might say well
imagine that you could take five
different domains of intelligence still
associated typing with with G and you
have people practice routines in all
five dimensions maybe you'd get
generalization under those circumstances
and the the results of the research
attempting that indicate that no as soon
as you move away from those specific
practice instances you don't get
generalization so that I mean I guess I
guess in some ways some of this is to be
expected from the consideration that
everything is an allocation problem
within within the body abraded that you
know by a large an improvement one
domain tends to be bought at the expense
of something else I you know you yeah
just that right and then
conscientiousness I can tell you some
research we've done that's cool although
we haven't been able to demonstrate that
it's actually improved conscientiousness
the first thing to note about
conscientiousness is that no one
understands it at all especially the
industrious this element there's no
plausible biological psychological neuro
physiological or animal models for
conscientiousness all we've got is self
reports we can't even find tasks that
conscientious people do better it's
unbelievable but who self reports really
a little freak or well you can get
reports from teachers and parents and so
forth but it's all human report okay all
the way we can measure it and we've Mike
in my lab we've probably tried 200 tasks
trying to find something that
conscientiousness conscientious people
do better no luck we can derive it from
Linkwood
analysis of verbal output now to some
degree but that's still that's not a
task you know yes yes so now we produced
a series of programs called the self
authoring suite and one of them the
Future authoring program it's a writing
program that helps people lay out their
plans for the future in detail so they
have to consider their their intimate
relationships their career goals their
educational goals their use of time
outside work their plans to maintain
mental and physical health their use of
drugs and alcohol they have to write for
15 minutes about what kind of life
they'd like to have if they were taking
care of themselves three to five years
in the future and then to write for the
same amount of time about how terrible
their life could be if all their bad
habits took control okay and then they
have to turn the positive vision into an
implementable plan we've managed to
improve their college grades by about
20% and drop out their drop the dropout
rate by about 25% over about 10,000
students now but you know we tried to
see if that was mediated by an
improvement in conscientiousness and
there was no evidence for that what it
was mediated what by was number of words
written during the exercise so it turns
out that thinking more about your future
helps the more you think about it the
more it helps and maybe that you know
maybe that would translate into an
improvement in conscientiousness across
time but there haven't been any credible
studies that I know of indicating that
there are exercises that can be done to
improve conscientiousness so that's also
you know troublesome and and worrisome
because that would be a nice thing to be
able to do yeah conscience I mean I
haven't thought much of it I don't know
much about the literature and Kutch it
just this is a trait what the word seems
to connote to me as an ordinary English
speaker has a strong social element to
it as well it's kind of like a coach yet
just person is somebody who doesn't
forget his obligations your index of
conscientiousness as a university
professor is you know somebody has asked
you to write them a reference letter for
getting it to graduate school or
whatever do you actually prioritize and
get the damn thing done on timers
there's some
but you'll just forget about it and
shove it to them somewhere else
I imagine cut edges this is having a
strong element of attentiveness to
social obligation as the well-being of
others the as it is defined the
personality literature doesn't have any
of that well I would say not so much
attention to the well-being of others
because that's more trait agreeableness
okay for the maternal dimension but
there's definitely a massive effect of
social obligation which is part of the
reason why conservatives tend to be
higher in conscientiousness than
liberals but it's not well-being of
others it's duty and so the
conscientious types may form and
maintain social contracts yes they
implement their plans yeah and they seem
to feel shame and self contempt when
they when they fail to live up to their
social obligations so that's another
thing that's interesting about the
income redistribution idea because it's
conceivable to me that conscientious
people would hate that because
conscientious people do very badly for
example if they're on if they're laid
off from work even if it's not their
fault they still take themselves apart
for their failure oh and so
conscientious people in particulars seem
to find in activity without productivity
highly aversive and aversive enough to
really cause them you know major health
problems so well that can that brings us
back to what we were discussing a little
while ago the problem of insuring that
large numbers people have access to
beautiful work in an age of which is
more and more the case that the big
components of the economy are moving
away with very few employees and that's
going to continue that's probably going
to escalate we're back to that same
topic to some extent yes and again I
mean I think I think any equality of
opportunity is sort of the thought of
our bedrock of inequality having its
impacts upon us
that's certainly the bottom of bedrock
of of why we should care about it
unmoral and social justice grouts it's
like well why should people who why
should what birthright affect the
opportunity is available to what and
it's also a social catastrophe because
hypothetically you want to set up a
society so that whatever someone has to
offer is maximally offer Abul to the
community because otherwise the
community loses yes that seems to me I
mean I think one of the great examples
of that although I don't think this
accounts for all of it is that the
relationship between the provision of
women's rights by countries and their
economic productivity is staggeringly
high so I think that also has to do with
openness in general to transformation
and change with with the provision of
women's rights being an index of that
but nonetheless it's a great predictor
of the eventual economic success well so
are partly an index and partly perhaps a
more direct effect but after all it's
slightly over half the population maybe
their talents are better utilized um
right well that's certainly what we
would hope and I think I think as you
said I think the evidence at least
suggests that yeah so okay so let me
recapitulate because we should probably
fold this up extend so so as far as I'm
concerned your work was revolutionary
because it undermined the general
proposition that the fundamental cause
of crime and violent crime in particular
was poverty instead you inflicted you
flipped it on ads so to speak and made
the made the claim well substantiated by
the research that it's relative poverty
that drives violent crime because of
status seeking primarily among young men
and although there are effects of
absolute privation and that would be the
poverty effect the the effects of
relative deprivation of status are much
more let's say especially in our
societies much more socially significant
yeah
and that the status competition itself
is driven at least in part by the desire
of men to attain status to obtain access
to two women roughly speaking and it's
partly because women outsource the
problem of mate selection to the male
competition domain right so the males
compete the women peel off the top it's
like a market solution in some sense and
then and then having pointed out that
inequality not only drives male homicide
but also tends to destabilize societies
there is an impetus for people to
consider how we can stop the winner from
taking all without becoming unduly
authoritarian about it or or or impeding
individual productivity given the fact
that there is individual variation in us
in the elements that actually produce
productivity that's our set of social
problems exacerbated by the fact that
we're going to be wiping out employment
for huge categories particularly of men
over the next 15 years yeah let me in
this context just make a point that I
spent most of a chapter of my book on of
that is that the notion that inequality
is somehow the engine of productivity
it's been pretty much rejected by
economists themselves in recent years
they've come to the conclusion that
relatively equitable places actually
have more economic productivity in the
ensuing period of time than those that
start up more inequitable there's a lot
of reasons for that the one that I think
is most striking that I would commend
people to look into is the concept of
useless if you like are wasteful
expenditure on guard waiver relatively
unequal societies and guard labor is a
term coined by the economist samples at
Arjen Jayadev and what they've showed is
that the number of people who are
employed in just jobs like being
security guards goes up as it equality
goes up it's no great surprise when you
think about it but you could define
guard labour more broadly or more
narrowly and the general result is that
a large proportion of people are engaged
in work then is it a sense
non-productive
it's just trying to prevent people from
using the property of other people add
that this is a very wasteful consequence
of extreme inequality of economic waste
that's reduced to relatively equitable
societies and there are others right
other way as the society becomes more
unequal it tilts towards
authoritarianism at multiple levels of
organization its own legislature yes
sorry I was just gonna say Edward
exactly and it's counterproductive even
from the point of view of simple you
know economic criteria of GDP and so on
that uh that inequality gets in the way
that for a bunch of reasons another
really interesting when the Bowles has
um has articulated in a recent book
Louis Bo wles said those people want to
look about I think it's what was called
the new politics of inequality of
redistribution that I liked it a lot
anyway one thing that he's shown that I
thought was very interesting it never
entered my head before I read him was
that the actual quality of goods in a
society can be damaged by severe
inequality when rich individuals of rich
firms have the capacity to keep
innovators and small companies from
establishing themselves you mentioned
the lore about the differences and
entrepreneurial undertakings and where
large numbers people were these small
business plans can't capitalize them
properly and can't get off the ground
you've actually got the phenomena of
people with lots of wealth and shoddy
products can drive people with better
quality products who are trying to get
started at the bottom Oh to the markup
yeah with negative results for just the
consumers right well that's a dieting
with having people stack up at zero zero
turns out to be a very very difficult
place to get out of because you can't
leverage yourself out of it no it
definitely knows really unequal
societies to like save Central American
societies it's also becomes increasingly
unpleasant for the people who are
wealthy because they're only wealthy in
a very narrowly defined way because they
can't go outside they
I'll let their children go out on the
into public because they'll get
kidnapped I mean the societies get
pretty ugly when the fences have to be
really high and yes and and so so yeah
so at the bottom of the regimental mug
the rich countries of the world those
problems are not absent I mean they're
certainly worse than the US they are in
Canada or most of Western Europe yeah
well alright that was really good I'm
very happy that you agreed to do a
podcast with Ian and I mean I found your
work well I definitely regard you as one
of the people who's been highly
influential on my thinking I mean I
think that work on relative poverty is
just and the effect sizes the work you
guys did in Chicago your work on
indicating the adaptive utility of of
uncertainty related dominus challenges
in unequal societies all of that's
brilliant I think can nicely
biologically predicated and the science
is done extremely soundly and it has
remarkable policy implications and you
know it changes the view around crime
and and and well and in a very important
way to tilt it over towards the
inequality side I think it's and it fit
so nicely and with the dominance
hierarchy literature and all of that
it's it's really profound stuff as far
as I'm concerned so I mean a glad you
had a chance to share it with everyone
thank you very much I appreciate those
kind words you can flattery will get you
everywhere yeah yeah well the thing is
the best kind of flattery is truth so
and I would certainly recommend that
people take a look at your book if
they're interested in what we've been
discussing again that's killing the
competition which is it's very readable
I would say it provides a lovely
argument with regards to inequality
addresses the major criticisms I think
very effectively and and starts to lay
out what is going to be an increasingly
necessary public discussion about how
civilized societies can can can ensure
that they don't collapse into two
extreme distribution into two extreme
distributions of wealth or other
resources it's a real danger it's a
cause
conscious constant danger needs to be
thought through in a dress very
intelligently so thanks again hopefully
maybe we'll get another chance to talk
hopefully a couple hundred thousand
people to watch this but that was a big
great thanks a lot you get what I need
on signing off okay thank you bye Joe